jean paul belmondo ne vous avais pas vu
sur l'écran depuis le casse on revoit
dans docteur popaul qui est un film qui
est accueillie avec des avis divers
certains trouvent ça très bien d'autres
ont des grandes réserves
j'imagine que vous avez trouvé ça très
bien et oui face à suresnes patrons des
médias c'est normal qu'on fasse sur des
réserves sur l'équipe surveille chabrol
qui est un homme très original et qui a
beaucoup de talent alors automatiquement
il fait pas exactement dans l'allemand
unis traiteraient classé qui seront là
toujours choqué un peu moi je suis pour
la beauté morale et la beauté morale je
ne la trouve que chez les mouche
et c'est ma soeur et je suis russe alors
un mois j'ai j'ai débuté avec chabrol
d'un double tour et j'ai pu de plus
volée de bois vert dans le rôle que je
jouais de lazlo kovacs je me suis fait
traiter de deux chargeurs d'acteurs qui
ne ferait jamais rien qui n'arrivera
jamais à rien nucléaire n'a jamais rien
dit ou finalement ce rôle m'a bien aidé
peut être que maintenant les critiques
on va dire que c'est la fin de ma
carrière avec ce rouge fait que le puma
sera très bien ce que je pense
tout le monde m'a raconté del mundo
c'est insensé avant de faire une grande
des scènes d'émotion racontines là dans
dix ans tourne et rats qui sont à
pleurer et oui mais ça veut dire que
j'ai toujours fait ça écrase et au
conservatoire prenez pas au sérieux
parce que j'étais décontracté on a
toujours reproché à l'art mais aussi à
l'armée je m'en fous pour faire carrière
dans l'armée mais elle au théâtre et au
cinéma même maintenant me veut je débute
un fils je vois les gens présents
inquiet parce que je tiens pas d'étrons
propos sur mon rôle je n'explique pas
les profondeurs et comment je vois que
ce personnage marche
j'explique pas comment va être sa
coiffure où s'installer ça choque
toujours beaucoup
ça ne suffit pas dans vos tiers mabec
solide pour michael jackon alors c'est
mieux comme reprises de faire des films
trop publie pas ce que c'est je suis
qu'un baume que j'ai fait ce métier
c'est pour que beaucoup de gens me
regardent jouer sinon je me mets devant
ma glace et puis je joue puis je me
trouve très bien
bon je crois qu'il faut pas avoir honte
d'être acteur est ce que ce soit c'est
un peu la mode dans son ombre beaucoup
d'acteurs 10e à exercer pas suffisant je
vais être autre chose faite
metteur en scène où on se lance dans la
politique à tout va pour montrer qu'on
est con et très profond
mais je trouve que de faire du bio c'est
déjà pas mal mais ce cas c'est une bonne
distraction et moi j'aime beaucoup ce
qui va la mousse est joué pour autre
chose
une trop bonne santé et oui et des dents
et ça se perd dans le cinéma